I'll tell you what I'm not gonna do
don't write this down I'll tell you what
I'm not gonna do I'm not gonna write
this even though that's I'm
approximating here approximating here
approximating here
can anyone suggest me why maybe this is
probably a bridge too far yeah okay so
these numbers here it's it's too far why
is this too far
why is this too far and you guys seem
like oh yeah yeah I make it you like you
enthusiastically naughty this is okay
why it's just a few numbers are it's not
what you think so this is one decimal
place this is zero decimal places why is
this such a big difference whereas the
what you think so the difference from
this line to this line is a difference
of 0.1 and it's moved but I could also
say there's a movement there's also a
movement between this line this line
isn't there I think but it's wider see
you like I just arbitrarily decided this
is this is wide enough and this is too
wide okay let me uh I'll weigh in to
tell you why I would go to this line but
not this one right if I write this down
this feels like whole number solutions
to me that's what it feels like right it
feels like I factorized and this is the
pair of numbers that I thought of and
then I'm gonna put them on right but I
did not these two numbers came from a
whole different place it came from surds
which I could never have guessed there's
a level of detail here that we don't
have okay now let's have a look now that
we know what these look like like we
have a sense of whether you could put
them on another line right I'm gonna put
them on our number line
- 5.9 took this one over here and then
0.9 I'm going to pop it about there okay
here's a really important point right I
needed to know where these two things
were the primary reason I needed to know
where they were is so that I could
position them in relationship to each
other okay let me show you what this
would look like if I didn't know right
if I looked at
the quadratic formula got an answer out
of it right and then I'm like cool once
minus ones plus I'm just gonna Chuck one
over here write this I'll tell you right
now I'm gonna shift away from thinking
mode into assessment mode for a minute
I would totally deduct a mark if I
source didn't do this
can anyone tell me what's qualitatively
different about this that like this was
fine but this is a big no-no you're
marking this you're looking at my
response now and I've drawn this right
why what's so bad about this like I'll
even I'll even label them with what
they're supposed to be I'm gonna say
well what's that three hmm I'm gonna say
this three - what why don't you like it
the vertex will be the y-axis so it'll
be like in the middle there like that
you like that's I'm interested because I
haven't said anything at the vertex yet
so I'm issues you have an instinct for
where it should be but it's not resting
what you think you ah the graph doesn't
have the scaling Y is scaling such a big
deal yeah sorry I thought you we don't
know the numbers yeah yep ah yes so when
I put these on right I mean just
eyeballing it it looks like that
distance is roughly the same as that
distance do you agree like I'm saying
they roughly say but they are clearly
not right one should be like six times
further away than the other one and
that's actually something we're
assessing when you're when you're
graphing this thing I want to know can
you accurately visually represent what's
going on and that is not an accurate
visual reputation variable the decimals
are there to help me position these
things okay but once I know where they
are
I'm gonna put them exactly there as in
once you get this point you tactic I've
done something wrong
that's really interesting I think that's
a understand that instinct because we
generally don't wanna make things messy
for you but that could totally be an
okay answer for a totally okay question
and it would be--look look a little
messy that's one of the reasons why we
check against things she's like am I
sure I should have get gotten 45 here
well I look back at my work and I'm like
yeah checks out right so I can have
confidence even though it's messy
well this is this is one of the areas in
which we sort of move away from just
simple things like you remember when you
first learn Python gross and remember
when you first learn Python rows all of
the triangles all the triangles were
like this guy right or maybe you got 5
12 13 right and it's like can't they
think of more numbers it's like well we
can but then we start making numbers
just disgusting I have no idea what
that's going to be right it'll be some
weird decimal okay and that was not what
we were focused on we were focused on
the relationships between the sides okay
here though we're we're past the point
where you know what to do with this we
want some precision as well he's just
age six now okay does that make sense so
we're gonna say you know what sometimes
you're going to get weird-looking
answers deal with it okay all right I'm
gonna put this on do we have enough
information to draw a line through all
of these you happy with it no why not
okay so so we sit down here we want a
vertex right now I'm gonna suggest you
could still draw something through this
right in fact I'm gonna do that right
now but it's just not I don't know a
hundred percent where it goes right I'm
gonna draw something and I think it
looks something like this
do you have something that looks roughly
like that now you might hurts like no I
don't mind if n't okay Wow
having your brother's keeper that's
handy okay so we're talking at the
vertex right you're like I don't and we
don't know where the vertex is I haven't
calculated just yet
okay now you will notice I've placed it
on the left of the axis I haven't
calculated where it is but I place it to
the left how do you think I knew it was
on the left
how do you think I knew the vertex is
going to have to be the axis of symmetry
I can get the vertex once I know where
the axis of symmetry is I don't know
where either am i right now but that axe
is symmetry it's some it's an axis of
symmetry it has to be symmetrical right
so it's got to be between these two guys
yeah do you have your ruler there maybe
pop your ruler thank you
so this is big enough thankfully okay
you can put your ruler there literally
right and you can say Oh on my on my
piece of paper that's like seven
centimeters well I should have picked an
even number eight centimeters right so
it 4 will be in the middle and there is
where I'm eyeballing right that's where
my axis of symmetry should be that's how
I actually drew it rastan correct
we do not know did you catch that rice
and said we do not know how how down or
up it is we don't know it's a vertical
position so I know roughly horizontally
where it is but I don't know precisely
and I don't know how far up or down so
let's go ahead and work this out okay
how can we find this axis of symmetry
well you said it was halfway between
these two roots halfway between it's the
average of the roots how do you find the
average between two numbers what do you
do you add them and then you divide by
two can we give that a go you've got the
two numbers here right if we add them
and then divide by two what happens